-My next guest is an Emmy-
and Grammy-nominated
actor and comedian.
You can see him in the show
"Schmigadoon!"
New episodes are available
Fridays on Apple TV+.
Here is Fred Armisen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-I don't --
-[ Laughing ]
-I don't have --
I didn't have glue.
-Oh, my --
-Dammit.
-Can you lean back, maybe?
How's it going, man?
-It's pretty good.
[ Laughter ]
I'm at the dentist.
-You're at the dentist
right now?
-Yeah, it's my dentist's office,
man.
-Why couldn't you
Zoom me from home?
-This is the appointments.
They were just at the same time.
[ Laughter ]
-I love that
you have mustaches around.
Fred, how are you doing?
I miss you.
Nice to see you.
-I miss you.
How you been?
Hi.
-I'm fantastic.
Hi, bud.
Yeah, I got this silly
mustache and beard.
This is a fake, Fred.
-It is?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I was kidding.
I was doing a joke.
Fred, have you been back
to 30 Rock since the --
since the pandemic?
-No, I have not been back.
It's been,
you know, over like a year.
Year and three months
or something.
-We miss you, bud.
Do you remember your first day
in 30 Rock, or first time
you came into the building?
-First time I ever went
to 30 Rock was to see
a dress rehearsal
of "SNL" in 1982.
Because a classmate of mine,
her dad was
a cameraman on "SNL,"
and The Clash
were gonna be on.
So, she was like, "Yeah,
I know you like The Clash.
Why don't you go see them?"
And I did.
It was incredible.
-No way.
You ended up doing --
I remember you did a sketch
with them for something,
where you were
eating rubbish or whatever.
You were a character --
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
-What was that for?
That was --
-That was for Funny or Die,
and they were promoting, like,
this box set of theirs.
And I told them
that I went to go see them.
I was like -- you know, I was,
like, being really earnest.
Like, "Yeah, you know,
I actually went
to go see you guys at 'SNL,'"
and they kind of made fun of me
a little bit.
They did a bit
where they were like,
"Oh, yeah, I remember you."
[ Laughter ]
-That's what you want from them.
-That's what you want, though.
-Yeah, that's what you want.
They're rock stars.
-"Oh, right, yeah,
you were in the crowd."
-"Yeah, you were the one
clappin', right?
In the audience?
I remember you."
[ Both laugh ]
That's a good bit.
Dude, I know
you just came from Italy.
You're shooting with our pal,
Molly Shannon.
How's Molly Shannon?
-Yeah.
Oh, she's great.
I feel like Molly Shannon
is someone who everybody loves.
You know?
Like, I always think like, "Oh,"
like, you know,
"That's like my friend."
And then it turns out
everyone loves her.
So she's very hypnotizing.
Like, when you talk to her,
she draws you in.
[ Light laughter ]
"Yeah!"
-[ Laughing ]
She does do that.
You're like,
"I was thinking that, too."
Yeah.
-Yeah.
-She's the greatest.
Well, I know that you're --
you're back doing stand-up,
which is exciting.
-Yes.
-This is a big deal.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So go see Fred.
Can you set up --
What can we expect in
a Fred Armisen stand-up special?
-Well, I've been
doing this thing
where I do strumming styles
from around the world.
-Strumming styles
-This is, like, basically,
kind of folk kind of rock,
but this is, like --
this is how they
strum a guitar in Australia.
So they're very confident.
They're like...
[ Guitar strumming ]
♪ You better believe it ♪
♪ Believe what you say ♪
You know, they're
very sort of like...
fast chord changes.
-Uh-huh.
And then, Canada's a little --
Canada's like a little wispier
and, like, a little more
sort of elaborate, like...
[ Guitar strumming ]
♪ Don't you know
it's my window again ♪
[ Laughter ]
That kind of thing.
The U.S.A. is --
You know, the strumming style
is very...
[ Guitar strumming ]
♪♪
And Americans like to pretend
like they can't hit a note
when they sing.
It's a...
[ Creaky voice ]
♪ Don't you know ♪
♪ It's a jar ♪
♪ Again ♪
♪ I know ♪
♪ Tomorrow ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Again ♪
♪ You know ♪
[ Chuckles ]
-Brazil.
Brazil is very close.
It sounds like the microphone's
right on them.
So it's like...
[ Singing in Portuguese ]
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
You are so funny.
-Colombia is very percussive.
♪♪
[ Singing in Spanish ]
[ Laughter ]
And then, Italy,
they like to do sort of
mid-tempo, a little slower
and they're like sort of...
[ Guitar strumming ]
[ Singing in Italian ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Ireland is very --
Ireland only likes to do
one chord. Just...
[ Guitar strumming ]
[ Rapping desk ]
[ Singing Gibberish ]
♪♪
-Yeah.
One, two, three, four!
[ Singing gibberish ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
One, two, three, four!
-That's it.
That's some of it.
-That's is in a nutshell
what we have to --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You are unbelievable.
Fred, can we talk about
"Schmigadoon"?
This is on Apple TV+.
I love the premise.
Basically, it's
Keegan-Michael Key,
Cecily Strong are a couple.
They get -- They go for a hike.
They're in a fight.
And they end up getting stuck
into a magical world
that is set in --
it's all musicals.
And they have to find true love
to escape this musical world.
-Yeah.
-I think you're perfect
to be in it.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Fred Armisen
in "Schmigadoon."
Take a look at this.
-Unfortunately,
no one seems to be interested
in my rhubarb squares.
-Oh, I love rhubarb squares.
-You do?
Me, too!
-And I thought
I was the only one.
-Well, they're definitely
not for everybody.
[ Coin rattles ]
-I'll take two.
-Wonderful.
-Here.
I'd hate to enjoy it alone.
-Oh, thank you.
-Eh, eh, eh, Howard.
Don't forget your diet.
We don't want to have
to get your fat pants
out from the attic again.
-Oh.
Sorry, Mildred.
-That's what I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Fat pants.
-That is Fred Armisen,
the one and only!
Oh, we love you, Fred.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love you. Thank you.
-New episodes of "Schmigadoon"
are available Fridays
on Apple TV+.